[Music]
foreign
are you ready for some heart pumping
action-packed excitement we're here to
take you on a journey through the top 20
most legendary fights in anime history
from epic one-on-one battles to team
fights these fights have become the
stuff of Legend inspiring countless fans
with their Unforgettable moments and
incredible displays of strength and
skill whether you're a seasoned anime
veteran or just getting started these
legendary fights are sure to leave you
breathless and begging for more so let's
dive in and explore what makes these
battles so Unforgettable let's start
things off strong with shimazaki versus
everyone
foreign
any discussion on Mob psycho fills me
with fond memories of the show there's
always something so amazing with every
season and all things considered this is
one of the best action anime there is if
you consider the whole package in
addition to a really great plot it's got
mind-bogglingly good animation that
enhances these moments Way Beyond The
Source material there are many
candidates and what I feel can be the
best fight in mob psycho but I've gotta
hand it to the shimazaki fight from a
technical standpoint this is probably
Peak anime fighting just look at the
camera angles the level of animation and
a masterful presentation of perspective
it really is a fight that you can
immerse yourself in and really feel that
you're in it there's things like this
that truly Elevate what's already a
crowning moment in the story don't let
the simplistic art style fool you in
terms of Animation this is as good as it
gets
if you want to talk about Dynamic
movement then you'll get more of it from
Samurai shampoo
a show that's largely been forgotten in
the sands of time Samurai Champloo was a
unique experiment in its day it wasn't
something I'd seen before when I watched
it during college and it certainly
remains unique even till now it feels
like a homage to the more westernized
aesthetic in anime that's more common
than you think in the early 2000s and
when you combine the sword fights with
hip-hop you get beautiful displays like
this our two leads find themselves in a
fight for their lives facing garia the
hand of God in this scene and largely
appraised the fight for its excellence
in presenting the signature Samurai
shampoo Flair with its choreography
we've also got to give some props to how
it emphasizes are to these philosophies
and emotions in it as I've said a couple
of times before battles and how people
approach them are some of the best ways
of showing character it's one of the
keys of Storytelling and this is a
textbook example of showing style and
contrast concerning our three combatants
please
[Music]
Nakamura versus hawk also brought in the
emotional impact
I think it's about time we had some
physical brawling into the mix don't you
think so and what better way to do it
than with a fight from Hajime no ippo
takamura versus hawk is by far my
favorite fight in the entire series and
I don't think you need any help to find
out why it's got the whole big fight
feel the whole Unstoppable force me to
move object Vibe and it more than
delivered for an anime about boxing it's
only fitting that it emphasizes the grit
the intensity the insane grind being in
the ring for several rounds entails
takamura vs Hawk has all of those in
Spades and more with me being so
immersed that each blow each heavy punch
that was given ample emphasis got me
really really hyped when it was all said
and done we just witnessed one of the
best fights a combat sport anime could
give us it's all about the emotion and
just letting everything sink in and this
one's a winner in that regard
want to get goosebumps one fight I'll
always go back to is daiguran versus
anti-spiral
you can use many words to describe ttgl
guren Lagan AKA triggers Masterpiece his
status may be debatable with the
Studio's impressive library but I think
that in terms of Legacy the show does
top it it also has a magical way of
being so inspirational yet so heart
pounding in its key moments the fight is
cool but what makes it so good is the
talking that's right that's what I said
the talking the exchange between diagram
and the anti-spirals is nothing short of
um uplifting if I do say so there's
something that really strikes me with
shows that are inherently human-centric
those that believe in the power of
humanity to strive and overcome even
fate and this fight just epitomizes that
theme bonus points for the opening song
playing throughout the final exchange
too I love love love love it when shows
do that especially with the song as good
as sariro days I really love guren Lagan
for the battles but more importantly the
numerous inspirational and empowering
themes it has littered throughout its
narrative
with you
on to some more light-hearted stuff
however here's one punch man
apart from a few dramatic Moments One
Punch man really is more of a
light-hearted show it's a parody and
that's the exact point of it the whole
over-the-top overpowered hero thing
really took off around about this time
and it's a formula to success but have
you seen saitama get serious well now
you do because in an effort to shake up
the formula a little bit you have this
fight with boros to their credit they
did try boros was sold as someone who
could finally be a threat to saitama and
it worked for a little while I suppose
the alien leader actually survived a
couple of saitama's punches even if his
body parts paid the price for it while
saitama's famed to be able to defeat
anyone with just one punch you're going
to wonder what would happen if perhaps
there did exist someone with defenses
that could prevent them from being
one-shotted while throwing bombs in
return at least until saitama Alicia's
serious punch and completely obliterates
boros let's back to the status quo we go
after that but still this fight remains
one of the best displays of planetary
level destruction and is one of the big
one punch man fans back in its Heyday
the fight is nothing short of Glorious
foreign
had one hell of a showdown as well
when it comes to Dragon Ball we've had a
lot of encounters to remember the
franchise being as old as it is and with
such a legacy gave us a lot of fights
that could have a place on this list
however I'd like to give a bit more
focus on super this time with it being a
bit less popular yet just as spectacular
honestly I wasn't sure if it was a good
idea to revive Dragon Ball in the 2010s
with super but realistically without
super we wouldn't have got some amazing
movies and this fight right here full
powered Ultra Instinct Goku was one of
the best highlights of super as a whole
seeing Goku and jiren Duke it out in an
unprecedented scale of Destruction was a
treat for Dragon Ball fans everywhere
seeing these kinds of cataclysmic fights
with modern art and animation really
made fans both new ones in the classic
90s kids hyped for a whole lot more is
this peak Dragon Ball super well with so
many other good moments on its resume
that is debatable but it is sure one of
the best fights he had to offer
but I don't think it can match this one
in terms of cultural footprint here's
jotaro versus Dio
foreign
fans know the series for taking a look
at it with a detached point of view
however shows that this was an awesome
fight in its own right even without
taking note of the cultural impact this
is an awesome fight that lived up to all
the expectations for a climactic fight
it's a long time coming and seeing
jordano and Dio finally get into it a
full force really made Stardust
Crusaders a favorite amongst the many
JoJo series it's also interesting that
while a lot of the JoJo fights ended up
being creative this one lived with the
concept of the rule of cool primarily
the most iconic fight and it's one where
the writers just seemingly threw stuff
out and showed off whatever seemed the
coolest and by god it works so well a
lot of that has to do with how much of a
master class this fight was in terms of
sound Direction you could tell the voice
actors had so much fun and energy during
this scene and bringing it to life for
us all to enjoy
[Applause]
coming right up we have one of the best
bleach fights of all Ichigo vs biakuya
what makes Ichigo versus biakuya special
well certainly not the power level as
these two were nowhere near the
overpowered monstrosities that the
bleach Universe had like Aizen and
Yamamoto the animation wasn't turning
heads back in the 2000s still I feel
that this fight is the best Bridge fight
had to offer due to the whole setup and
the progression of the fight it had so
many emotional stakes and even now it
showed how good bleach can be with the
power levels just toned down a little
all you need to do is build up the fight
properly and make it a great payoff all
while creating a great back and forth
between our Plucky protagonist and a
seemingly unbeatable obstacle this is
the fight where biakuya first found
himself in real trouble and Ichigo
always seemed to have another Ace up his
sleeve to counter whatever the opponent
had to throw at him and this actually
felt natural and earned in contrast to
the Shonen special of people randomly
whipping out counters until one guy runs
out and loses as a standalone fight
Ichigo vs biakuya is pretty plain even
if it's really good being practically
the final battle of an arc taken with
context it's Peak bleach the fight that
caps off the French size is best Arc
Ade
foreign
[Music]
yes I intentionally put this right after
bleach considering how similar the two
are to each other however one thing
bleach doesn't have is a tournament Arc
one where this next fight took place
which puts yusuke against doguro in our
protagonist best fight to date the whole
tournament had so many Unforgettable
fights but this Clash is what everyone
was waiting for you skate taking on
doguro and all his power we're used to
the saying a David vs Goliath fight but
this fight is where that saying gets
taken literally and to ridiculous
proportions too it's the climax of the
tournament that we all deserve for one
there was a real sense of danger here as
yusuke looked really outmatched and then
there's the whole implication of this
fight and how it relates to both yusuke
and doguro's goals and philosophies this
is a great way to wrap up doguro's
storyline that was started with his
backstory and his eventual goal that
pushed him to become the monster that he
is great storybook ending with this one
[Applause]
thank you
let's go back down to the Earth for this
next fight now shall we Spike versus
Vincent is where it's at
with most of the previous fights
featuring Supernatural powers and all
things about time we go to something a
little bit more grounded and this Cowboy
Bebop fight is the right mix of grounded
yet thrilling it captures the magic of
Classic Hollywood fights combining
physical brawling and a bit of gunfire
it's all exciting to watch unfold Cowboy
Bebop really was a treasure of its time
and one I wouldn't claim that this fight
encapsulates everything that I love
about the show it's a good Showcase of a
very important part of the show The
Action sequences in the show are fire
and the characters all had this unique
Charisma and energy that improved the
atmosphere of their conflicts
[Applause]
and if you're enjoying the video so far
then please make sure you leave a like
I'd really appreciate it we continue
with another fight featuring supporting
characters King Bradley versus Scar
right here
[Music]
FMA is not exactly an anime known best
for its fight I mean don't get me wrong
it's got some great action but when
people think of FMA it's the themes and
the characters people gravitate to not
the fights but I argue that some of the
best moments of the show involve
completing character arcs and showing
the conclusion of Journeys through its
fights almost all which have meaning the
one that stands out to me the most
though is King Bradley vs scar both are
really strong characters as far as
development's concerned and after
letting us get a glimpse of their past
and their Journeys to get to the Final
Act of Brotherhood I did find it poetic
that it's these two who duke it out for
King Bradley's Last Dance It's a Fight
where both combatants gave and lost it
all with both expected and unexpected
turns coming in I wondered how scar
would overcome King Bradley's
overpowered abilities and I was pleased
with the way things developed
[Music]
in the same vein we have another fight
involving a seemingly Invincible villain
in Kenshin versus shishio
[Music]
not to say that shishio's skill in
swordsmanship holds a candle to the
insane Clairvoyant abilities King
Bradley had but in the same vein this
sadistic swordsman is the Kenshin
Universe strongest villain taking hiko
out of the picture he has no pier in
one-on-one combat and for someone like
Kenshin who already handicapped himself
in the battle with his oath never to
kill that's a ruthless villain that's
impossible to overcome on paper it's
those kinds of setups that make fights
like these so exciting you never know
what's gonna happen entering it and true
to expectations the fight had a lot of
twists to continue keeping things
interesting you have people joining the
fight one after another Revelations
involving shishio and some legitimate
heartbreaking moments that further
solidify both kenshin's resolve and
shishio's cruelty it's a fight that took
me on an emotional ride and it's
something you only experience by
watching Rurouni kenshin's Kyoto Arc
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
Luffy and Luchi had one of the best
fights one piece ever had
hello
I've noticed that it's been a while
since I talked about Luffy versus Lucci
and that's a shame really I was too
focused on getting pumped up with all
the recent content with kaido or the
stuff that people will remember like Ace
and Whitebeard moments that I felt like
I overlooked what I felt was a really
really great battle well that changes
today for Luffy versus Lucci is yet
another of the great fights one piece
gave us and it's largely to do with the
Thematic value to it it's a very
meaningful fight that exemplifies the
Clashing of two drastically Different
World Views it really helped push forth
one piece's overall theme of pushing
forward the value of freedom and the
willingness to put everything on the
line the fight itself is great with some
tense moments but I really love this
fight for the symbolic value behind it
it also showed Lucci that the type of
opponent he had to be scared of isn't
the strongest one but the one with the
firmest heart
Yuji and Toto vs Hanami is a
quintessential example of the power of
modern animation
if you needed even more reason to
respect the hard work our animators do
the way they painstakingly bring to life
some of the biggest moments in the manga
we enjoy well here's something for you
to Feast your eyes on there's a lot to
like about this fight I've repeatedly
featured this fight and focus more on
the chemistry between Yuji and Toto as
well as how this fight Illustrated their
growing Bond and Trust in one another
now I still stand by those words but
also give the central Spotlight on just
how great the animation for this fight
is Jiu Jitsu Kaizen has had a lot of
mind-blowing moments gifted To Us by
mappa and the hard-working staff but
this one Takes the Cake when you look at
just how much love and work went into
the fight choreography it just doesn't
hit us hard in manga form right but with
the fight choreography done by the guys
at mapa this has quickly become the
class to remember if we're talking Jiu
Jitsu Kaizen
speaking of insane animation how's team
tengen versus [__] and gyotaro
I'm sure that everyone knows it when it
comes to fight animation and production
values few can beat you for tables best
heck it's because of this type of
Animation the Demon Slayer Rose to fame
exploding into popularity well into its
run sure the animation and the overall
atmosphere of the rui fight is insane
but it just felt like it was lacking in
a lot of things for example emotional
Stakes or the chance to let those
involved show of the best of their
abilities and play off each other that
however gets taken care of in the
climactic battle in the red light
district arc on paper this is an overly
long fight but it never felt that way
when you're watching it it also manages
to get everyone involved and rightfully
so because unlike with rui the heroes
are dealing with upper Moon demons this
time there's also the thing with way
higher Stakes because now it's not just
an isolated Forest incident but one
where the light of so many are at stake
and with strong enemies that the heroes
can't just brute force their way through
it does add another dimension of
suspense you just can't wait to see how
the heroes get to all the positive
defeating the two and just when you
think they've got it more complications
arise before you know you're near the
end of the arc already well what else
can I say that's one immersive fight
that makes this season of Demon Slayer
so good
luolang vs nanashi is a great way to
wrap up an outstanding movie
for people who know sword of the
stranger these days but it's one of the
anime movies our field has definitely
stood the test of time just looking at
it it doesn't seem like something that
the modern anime fans would likely
gravitate to want to win but the whole
hour and a half watching the movie is
definitely worth the time it's got some
jaw-dropping sequences awesome plot and
setting and the rightful dose of
violence for the genre of movie and it
also had something that I really look up
to highly in anime a sense of conclusion
a nice way to wrap everything up both
narratively and philosophically sword of
the stranger does just that and gives us
this epic battle along with it nanashi
and luolang's fights in the film's
finale really is one of the best fights
in anime movie history if we're talking
from a pure sword fighting perspective
great back and forth and a somber yet
pumping atmosphere to get everyone in
the mood makes this an excellent climax
and if you want to talk about hype and
build up there are a few things capable
of beating Naruto vs Sasuke
it's been there from the store it's been
established ever since that eventually
we'll have Naruto vs Sasuke the story
between the two just writes itself and
while they had their series of fights
littered around Naruto and Naruto
Shippuden the final fight does take the
crown it's a fight that is mostly
carried by the story and the clashing
philosophies of the two but don't tell
me you didn't feel excited to see these
two finally at their peak of their
powers go all out end of the series
fights are great because of how much the
power level has been raised to that
point and this one is no exception also
it isn't overly long and every moment
counted when the two characters poured
their hearts out in fighting each other
it's the final battle and rightfully so
it's got the build up it's got the
Thematic element to it and it definitely
didn't come out of nowhere like garguya
did the battle ending the perfect way it
did with a physical draw yet a clear
philosophical winner is the icing on the
cake
we're not quite done with storied
rivalries yet as Here Comes gintoki vs
takasugi
Kentucky and takasugi have been through
a lot the two foils might as well be
siblings and they've had a long history
of blood and betrayal thus it's
inevitable that the two would have to
cross blade somewhere down the line
somewhere like episode 304 where the two
of them Collide to decide things once
and for all what I love about this fight
is that it's long but filled with
background content dakasugi and gentoki
have a relationship that's simply full
of intrigue and it was all laid out in
this fight as it should be that helped
increase the emotional gravity of the
battle and along with how the two fought
their hearts out it's that that makes it
such an immersive fight the fighting is
good but it's the story that really
pushed this fight up a notch the shared
dialogue between the two was the Tipping
Point this is one of my favorite hero
rival Dynamics right here it's a great
farewell to dakasugi before he
temporarily leaves the story
let's feature a fate fight now too after
all before Demon Slayer fate was you for
tables claim to fame for the general
audience
come on
saber and Ryder didn't have a storied
rivalry but the sheer Insanity of the
animation makes this a noteworthy fight
UFO table always brought their a game in
their big Productions and the theatrical
adaptation of Heaven's feel the final
Mainline fate route that came out in
anime form was just the perfect place
for them to bring out their prowess the
fights just all sorts of wild with the
movement the environmental destruction
the attack effects and the like on
another note I'm also just glad that we
got to see Ryder go all out and even
match saber for far too long Ryder's
been getting pushed aside or taken out
early in the gray War but who knew all
it took was a halfway decent Master for
her to contest even the mighty saber in
this show of skill it wasn't technically
the final battle in Heaven's field but
it might as well have been for some
people the Shiro vs girei battle
afterwards felt more like an
afterthought
[Applause]
and here we have two of the strongest
characters in the series taking on each
other in a fight to death nettero and
maryum's fight remains one of my
favorite Mentor fights I think it paved
the perfect way for nataro to go pushed
meruim up the ranks in terms of
reputation and overall created a major
moment for fans to remember I think the
fight brings a lot to the table besides
the actual action for one you've got the
roles being switched here as meruim
actually acts more heroic in this fight
looking for a dialogue instead of
Destruction on one hand some can point
to notaro's role as a villain while the
others say that it's not all Justified
due to how much is at stake against the
Chimera ants it's not something you see
every day from a Shonen and that kind of
writing is why I love Hunter Hunter so
much as for the action itself well it's
also a fight where everything had to be
precise for nataro and it's also the
first and last time you see him push to
the point of doing what he had to do and
pull a noble sacrifice it's one of the
best fights of all time
foreign
whoa that's 20 fights done and now it's
time for you to share what your top
finds in anime are I'm positive I
overlooked some which didn't make it but
isn't that just a testament to how much
anime as a medium can touch our hearts
and get us feeling pumped and excited
thanks for watching and I hope you'll be
back for the next list